it's good man I'm glad you're coming
here before you go to sleep man you know
you're going to have Jesus on your mind
you know maybe he'll show up your
alhamdulillah okay um went through the
Book of Genesis and then went through
Exodus okay alhamdulillah I noticed uh
God calling a lot of people his children
and then then I came to Surah maram
chapter 19 verse 37 and I thought where
have I seen this before
and then I went to John 2017 and lo and
behold there it was minus the father oh
so what so it wasn't there
then so essentially in John
2017 yeah he says I'm sending sending to
my Lord and your lord my father and your
father which is not what the Quran says
right father my God and your God yeah so
that which is not what the Quran says
right well Quran on
inah right uh verse
37 I think it
was so that kind of put into context for
me alhamdulillah which was essentially
bring let me bring how can it I I know
what it says how can it put it into
context when Jesus says that he has the
father and God is our father as well the
Believers when the Quran and there goes
strictly against
that yeah so let me bring this up 1937
right so this is alluding to your early
church fathers isn't it
saying uh Surah so Chapter 19 Verse on
one second one second YouTu YouTu
they're saying your mic is low I can
hear you perfectly fine though but
they're saying that they they can barely
hear
you uh okay is this any better you might
you might have to speak up a little bit
I know you said you're about you're
about to go to bed but you might just
have to just speak up just a little bit
before me
explain yeah no problem um so
essentially 1937 so as I'm reading Surah
basically the story
ofam mother of Jesus peace be upon it um
yeah so he goes into there and uh in
this chapter they essentially the Jewish
people brother I I don't I I know the
story I I know sir Mariam I know all of
that kind of stuff my question is how
does it put in perspective John 2017
when that clear clearly goes against
everything Islam
teaches so what does it what does it go
against he says that God is his father
in John
2017 right so what do they mean by
father how many it doesn't matter is is
Allah a father in any
sense so what does Father mean to you
doesn't matter is Allah a father in any
sense is there any meaning by which
Allah's a
father not in the sense that you have
taken it do okay do you explain let's
not do this do you you you hear me
saying any sense
right yeah okay is there any sense that
Allah is a
father in any sense no not the meaning
that's been attributed I'm I'm going do
it again because you keep saying no not
in the meaning that is attributed to him
right now last chance bro cuz it sounds
like you're playing games with me okay
is there any
sense is there any
meaning any sense
any in which Allah is a
father no thank you so it doesn't matter
what I mean or what Jesus meant by it or
what the scripture meant by it it
doesn't matter because Allah is not a
father in any sense that the scripture
might have said cuz he's not a father in
any sense yep so John
2017 directly goes against everything
that's taught in in in Islam about Allah
being a father he's not a
father yeah but then we've also got
verses in the Bible that essentially
sayate other people are God's son
doesn't matter that that and that goes
against the Quran
right uh yeah essentially so then why
you so you're showing me continuously
that the prophets and the bi the
biblical prophets contradict the Quran
that's what you're showing me yeah so
then I've got a theory on this I believe
that at some point the Sun the word Sun
wasn't indicative of begotten or a child
that was born why does that again why
does that
matter it matters because we've got
David as the Son of God hold on stop
stop stop stop stop why does it matter
in which way someone was identified as a
Son of God when Allah is not a is not a
father at all or there is no son of
Allah at all in any way so why does it
matter if it's in the sense of begotten
or if it's if it's a term of endearment
why does it matter when neither of those
are correct for
okay brilliant so I believe that Allah
may have allowed it in the past and
because it was
misconstrued to be to be to associate
partners with him that he was removed
from the Quran got it where do you get
that
from like I said that's my theory yeah I
know where did you get that
from from the fact that you should
assign no Partners to God that He Shall
take no Idols beside no that's not
that's not that's not helping me you're
just telling me what you what your Quran
says where do you get it from that that
Allah once was allowed allowed himself
to be identified as the father where is
that anywhere in your
Quran so I'm just saying that from from
the fact that essentially in if the Old
Testament is the word of God and the
word of God can't be corrupted right and
therefore at some point it was allowed
and therefore it was misconstrued and
therefore in the Quran which is like
version 3.0 of the same religion right
essentially God took that away and said
like okay no longer are they allowed to
call me father because it's been
misconstrued therefore I'm taking that
right away from them got you so you're
saying that because the Old Testament is
the word of God and it can't be
corrupted people just
misinterpreted uh and misc conscrew
Father and Son but which but God you
know all allowed it before okay so then
that means the Old Testament is the word
of God it can't be corrupted so when it
says that the Messiah in Psalm 2 is the
begotten Son of
God is that that that means that that's
the word of of of God and that's true
then
right interesting yeah because that's
old test yeah that's Old Testament
that's not new Psalms Psalms what sorry
psalms 27 the one where you said that it
was about David it's not about David
it's about the
Messiah it's in all because the Jewish
people seem to think it's about David as
well no the Jewish people understand to
Psalm 2 to be about the Messiah he's
speaking prophetically about the Messiah
it's even when you when you check the
tars Jonathan when you check uh when you
check a couple of even rinic Traditions
Psalm 2 is about the Messiah not
David So psalms 27 is a verse from a
passage written by King David that
records the words of God's son Israel's
Future King
see right okay so let's see what the
Jewish people translate this
as Jewish
translation
okay ask of ask it of me and I
will it's loading just give me a second
it's okay take your time all right here
we go so let me tell of the decree the
Lord said to me you are my son I have
fathered you this
day
okay so this is David speaking yep he's
speaking prophetically about the Messiah
not about
himself I fathered you this
day yep it's talking about the day that
he has anointed him as king over the
Nations
all right verse six says as for me as
for me no not David I I'll say it again
because I need you to listen so I don't
have to repeat myself over and over
again come on
explained David is prophetically
speaking about the Messiah not
himself as you saw the breakdown you saw
it said that David is talking about
God's speaking the words of God's Future
King right that's what you read before
you opened it right well that was the
Christian version now this is Jewish
it's not a Christian versin it's just
what it
is no this is the
jewish. and here it's slightly
differently worded yeah because that's a
are you you're reading JPS
translation sefaria.org and it
is it should tell you at the top what
translation it is it's most like it's
the JPS that's what the website uses
right it's a paraphrase GPS that's right
yeah yeah it's a paraphrase not a word
for word
translation ah so they paraphrased in
here right yeah so if I was to go to
some Jewish people and say to him what
does this verse mean and who does it
refer to you're going to say that this
is referring to the Messiah yeah yeah
well they they won't say Jesus they'll
say the Messiah though but my my
question to you is is why would a why
would a Jew be your
Authority why would a jaw what Jew what
sorry why would why would you make a Jew
your Authority on what the scripture
says
I don't know because they've St to
monism do they accept Jesus as the
Messiah nope so then why would you trust
them to tell you who the Messiah
is no but I would trust them not to
associate partners with God though
doesn't
matter it does it doesn't matter you you
can't use you disagree with these people
fundamentally but then are trying to go
with their interpretation because you
know that they'll try to disagree with
Christians
no I'm going with their because they've
not associated partners with God yet
okay so just stick to the scripture
instead of trying to make people that
you disagree with fundamentally your
Authority okay so the scripture said
okay good so stop saying oh what would a
Jew say what would a Jew say no just go
with what the scripture says here yeah
so the scripture is talking about the
anointed one the Messiah that's verse
two it says that they're raising the
armies are going against the Lord and
his Messiah anointed one Messiah then
continuing done is talking about the
Messiah all the way through and says
that he's the begotten son of of the
fathering of the day he like a tree
planted beside the stream of water which
yeld with fruit and Seed Fage never
Fades and whatever it produces thrives
not so the wicked rather they are like
the cha that wind that the wind blow
what verse are you reading the wicked
therefore the wicked will not survive
what what verse are you reading my
brother
um the well I started from the beginning
and I just gone to verse five now not so
the wicked of four not so the wicked
rather they are like the cha that the
wind blows away therefore the wicked
will not survive judgment nor will the
sinners in the Assembly of the righteous
for the Lord cherishes the way of the
righteous but the Way of the Wicked is
do dude you're not reading the right
you're not in Psalm 2 oh Psalm two yeah
here we are
now Psalm two why Nations assemble and
people plot vain things Kings of the
Earth take their stand and Regent
Regents Intrigue together against the
Lord and against his anointed and in the
Hebrew there the the word anointed there
is
Messiah so anointed anyone was
been had oil put on there well actually
this one is the Messiah against the Lord
and his Messiah his
Messiah right so here I've got SS to
into JPS it says anointed
yeah that's the yeah that's the
translation of the word m messia is
Anointed one in the English or
Messiah right okay interesting so it say
so you see how it's talking about the
Lord and his Messiah and so and David is
speaking David is speaking prophetically
here talking about the Lord and his
Messiah the Nations R rising up against
them and how God speaking of his his
Messiah sets his King on his holy Hillel
and then David says or speaking in
prophetically the words of the Messiah I
will tell her the decree the Lord said
to me you are my son today I have
begotten
you so one second here in the JPS one
right it said then he speaks to them in
Anger terrifying them brother I don't I
don't care about the JPS as a paraphrase
I just told you that why you do why why
are you continuing to read a paraphrase
so one second but I have installed my
king on Zion my Holy Mountain so was
Jesus installed as a king on yes yes
he's the king of the Jews he's the king
of the Jews and especially this is also
this is double fulfillment here he's set
as king and he's sitting at the right
hand of the father right now and then
he's also going to come back and
establish God's Kingdom on
Earth so one second so the wor before he
said then he speaks to them in Anger
terrifying them in his wait because
you're focusing your focus using on the
wrong thing the pay attention to the
main point do you see here how the
Messiah is identified as the begotten
Son of God no because I'm seeing what
I'm seeing here is explain read read
verse uh six read verse I'm sorry
seven yeah but I can't read it in
isolation can I you can't because it's
talking about the Messiah so read it in
read it in read verse
seven right bro listen I'm give go go
ahead and read verse seven go ahead and
read verse in
isolation in isolation let me tell the
let me tell of the decree the Lord said
to me you are my son I have fathered you
this day so he's talking
to
David on
the wasting my time go get some go get
some rest explained go to go to bed go
get some rest